i've got some breaking news to bring you  here on the newshour it concerns the  british 100 meter relay silver medalist  cj uger and we have been told in the  past few minutes  uh that cj ugga has been suspended for a  doping violation obviously following the  success in the olympics in tokyo the 4  by 100 meter relay the sample was  collected by the ita we're told under  the testing authority of the  international olympic committee uh  during an in competition anti-doping  control back on the  6th of august uh following the final of  as i say the men's four by uh 100 meter  relay final  of the olympics in tokyo the result was  reported by the wilder accredited  laboratory of tokyo two days later on  the 8th of august so that is cj ooja  suspended for a doping violation the  athlete does have the right to request  the analysis of the b sample so a major  update there concerning c j ujid who  does have the right to appeal for and  get another  test